foreign
it's everybody's favorite lightning
rounds
all right today we're talking about work
and Leadership and I have not seen these
questions and so Kelly is going to let
them rip let him rip all right how do I
separate my career and my identity
oh gosh
um your your career is a job
it's it's a it's a way to earn a living
your
um identity is who you are moving
through the world and so the way I would
say that is one of the identities I've
chosen to take is
um I sit with people
uh who are hurting I I sit with
struggling people I did that when I
worked at Burger King I worked at Burger
King for four years worked my way up to
assistant manager what up but I worked
at Burger King
um I also was a dean of students I also
was a professor I also now I'm a
YouTuber for God's sake and in every one
of those jobs my my identity was I sit
with hurting people and lunch rush at
Burger King people are standing in line
exhausted dead-eyed
and it's hurting people all through that
line and people call into the show
people are hurting it's all to the line
so your identity is like who you are why
are you why are you operating in the
world and your job is the way you make
money if you're really really lucky
those two things can can work together
all right as a leader I need to have an
awkward conversation with a direct
report how do I start the conversation
this is going to be an awkward
conversation
I think any other way around that
usually one of two things happens and
I've done both of these incorrectly you
have like a hey how's it going how's the
fam oh yeah how's little Timmy did his
play go well great that's awesome hey
you're fired like there's that way which
is just catches everybody off guard
there's the you walk in and you feel
like it's a funeral you can feel the
weight in there and the you're nervous
as a leader and a boss you're nervous
I'm scared I'm uncomfortable
um that's true too the best way is to
say hey we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation this is going to be awkward
for both of us
um here we go and you you gotta start
bathing before you can I've had that
conversation
um you're gonna have to start putting on
deodorant have that conversation
um I've had all those uh conversations
so it starts with this is gonna be an
awkward conversation and if possible let
me add this this is going to be an
awkward conversation and I need you to
know I'm on your I'm on your team on
this but here's what has to happen
all right my team went to a happy hour
one of them made an inappropriate joke
that made others uncomfortable all right
bro how do I talk to them about it very
just like that
um
just being off-site just being drunk is
not an excuse It's a context right and
so
um if you get drunk and you say stupid
stuff at a bar well those people are
gonna who you're gonna see on Monday and
it goes with you and um not that this
has ever happened to me in my life I've
never gone out and said something
inappropriate and had to look at those
people on Monday ever in my life
um but you have that conversation direct
the same as you would at work because
it's inappropriate it's inappropriate
it's inappropriate
all right
Kelly what that was that was that
somebody put that in for you by the way
no but I always laugh at the Christmas
party every year because there's always
one or two people that you're like man
Monday morning it's gonna be awkward
they gotta come back I remember a few
years ago Joe Levitt was like uh the guy
who who he's worked in the company in
live events for a long time he's he's
institution here he's awesome but he got
up and he goes listen this is a
Christmas party and you gotta know where
I work at Ramsey Solutions Christmas
parties are
they're unfathomable like it's it's it's
chaos it's unbelievable and he said
this is a Christmas party don't lose
your job don't lose your job what do you
do don't you know I mean and I thought
what are we doing and then I got in
there I was like oh there's some of
y'all are gonna lose your job yeah
there's always a couple personal brands
that take a hit that night oh yeah
that's right all right so I made a big
mistake that could cost the company a
lot of money Kelly
when I took over this show
um how do I own up to what happened
gracefully
you ask your supervisor your leader for
um some time and then you walk you make
sure make sure I've made this mistake
too make sure you have your facts in a
row
and sometime one time that's the whole
other story I'll get into it I've
thought I've made mistakes to the tune
of three quarters of a million dollars
before the spreadsheet error
um and then I thought I've made the
worst mistake it wasn't that big it was
25 000 bucks and over the course of a
multi 100 million dollar company it's
not that big a deal
but you walk in and say I've made a
mistake I screwed something up I made an
error here's what I think the extent of
the damage is and if you've got one or
two ideas here's what I think I can do
to help but I'm open for any questions
you have and so I'm taking ownership of
it as Jocko says extreme ownership I
screwed this up even if you're um like a
mid manager and one of your people
screwed up you're the boss walk in and
say this happened on under my watch
don't be one of those leaders it's like
hey this guy did this happened under my
watch one of my staff members did X Y or
Z I'm the leader I'm taking ownership of
it and you might get fired
your integrity is not worth a job you
might get demoted your demotion is not
worth your job like that's not worth
your job go in there and say this is
what happened this is what it cost
here's what I think I can do to help and
often your boss is gonna say god sakes
don't do anything that your solution is
terrible I got a better solution we'll
work together
all right
um hey that's a much gentler much nicer
we got a lot of feedback about the
timers how mean y'all there are to me
see okay good way to go America thank
you no we didn't get comments about that
we got comments about the timer okay yes
because it hurt my feelings go ahead
yeah that's what my concern is
all right I know you have feelings on
this one because we've talked about it
before should you be friends with
co-workers no just kidding
um all right here's my thoughts on
co-workers and Friends yes you're gonna
work I mean we work so closely together
of course we're friends and I care about
folks and yes we're gonna have close
friendships
and
you gotta have people outside of work
here's what can be unfair
it can be unfair if your only friend
Community is your workmates and then you
come up with a personal struggle hey I'm
struggling with my drinking I'm
struggling with my mental health I'm
struggling with XYZ and you dump that on
a co-worker who then has to decide do I
want to stay employed here with this
huge secret
um I mean do I want to stay employed and
I've got to communicate to the
leadership hey this person's not fit to
be a nurse or a hospital aide right now
they're struggling with opioid addiction
or do I have to choose my friendship
over my personal responsibility my
ethical responsibility my work
um and keep this thing a secret that's
not that's not a fair position to put
somebody in and so I can often hear like
man I can't believe you told I can't
believe you told so have some friends
outside of work that you can divulge
everything to that you can be honest
with you don't keep secrets from
um and yes have close close friendships
I just know I'm not gonna put Kelly in a
position to I'm not gonna come and be
like hey Kelly guess what happened this
weekend to where she's got to think
I might have to report this to my
supervisor because John shouldn't be
doing a show on marriage because he's
got 14 right right I'm not gonna put in
that position right I don't have trust
me
I'm not 14 anything 14 anything but you
did not always agree that co-workers
should be friends no I've come around a
little bit on it yeah that was the
minimalist had a lot yeah
those two guys are brothers and uh I've
come around but those two guys also have
a level of uh safety and understanding
and Care
um if one of them came and said I had an
addiction Josh wouldn't fire Ryan be
like oh well you're not a minimalist
anymore maximalist right or if like Josh
bought a fancy couch he would be like
you're a fight like that's not how that
works that's not how their agreement
Works
um at most workplaces there's codes of
conduct there's lines you can't cross
and I think it's important that you
don't
double down on secrecy because Secrets
will kill you
um and you end up with this double life
and it just comes out it always comes
out and it comes out in explosions don't
do it don't do it have friends outside
of the office too but but yes you're
gonna have friends people you care about
don't button we're for we're there for
life because we rock for life we rocked
that's all I'm saying
all right I have a co-worker that
doesn't have good hygiene how do I say
something without hurting their feelings
oh is this about me no but I swear it's
nobody in this room there's Nate right
there I'm looking at Nate come on Nate
um I've had that conversation multiple
times in my career and it goes back to
that original thing you bring him and
say hey this is an awkward conversation
um I've gotten multiple requests hey let
me say this
if you have experienced somebody's not
showering you've experienced somebody's
body odor it could be cultural it could
be a homeopath there's always that
homeopathic person in the office it's
like I'm using crystals instead of
deodorant you're like we all can tell
right or whatever
um I just rub plants on my face and I
don't smell anymore it's like you for
sure do or I brush my teeth with
charcoal whatever your thing is
oh gosh the the the toothbrush people
are coming for me it's cool man I've got
charcoal toothpaste too everybody back
it down a notch
um now I lost my trans oh if you've
experienced it don't call somebody into
your office and say
hey man a bunch of people are telling me
because when you do that people start to
think everybody's out to get them and
they're not be a person of integrity and
courage and say I'm experiencing
you've got extreme body odors becoming
very hard to work with you you gotta
take a shower you gotta wash your
clothes are you struggling financially
doing some help I've had one time I had
to have that conversation with a student
and their response to me was I can't
afford soap
and I said man we got you we've got a
special fund for that but they couldn't
afford soap right that's how they were
living so
um be Grace graceful and be um direct
and be kind and be on the same side of
the same team same team but one question
I have on that so the question is I have
a co-worker so is that something that as
a co-worker is that something that you
take to who doesn't want to know if they
have a booger on their face
or a humongous like white zit like
somebody hey will you tell me like I
want somebody to know I can something in
my teeth I would I would think less of
you as my friend if I finished an
episode of the show and I've got like a
huge thing in my teeth and I've got like
I care my friend tell me right that's
what I would expect that same as bathing
it had a little piece of biscuit today
and I told you I appreciated it yeah
because then I would be walking around
with that biscuit on my face and if
someone's talking to you like hey I
hard conversation real quick dude you
have coffee breath so much that I think
that you would knock down a small child
I want to know that I want to know that
I'm gonna brush my teeth I'll go with
some mints or something I just don't
want to be dragon breath guy the whole
day yeah if I've had something about
teeth and I've talked to about multiple
people makes me so angry yes it makes me
think you're not a good human yeah
you're not a good person exactly all
right
um
I don't think my leader leads our team
well right I've been telling Chris that
I'm just kidding go ahead should I talk
to their leader about it oh the old end
around
and I realized on a show that's often
about sex I shouldn't have said the old
end around
um
I reserve that's that's a nuclear option
for me I reserve that for ethical
violations and ethical dilemmas like
somebody's asking me to do something
that lacks Integrity they're asking me
to steal to cut Corners to change
numbers to whatever or I'm witnessing
this person themselves have unethical
Behavior they're fudging timesheets
they're they're whatever
um then yeah I will
um
in my life when I've experienced that I
have looked in the mirror and said what
if this can I tolerate and what if it's
going to not tolerate once or I think
twice I've left I've left I've chosen to
go because I don't want to work in this
environment other than throw grenades
because again that's just not who I am
um and other times I've I've been like
uh this particular boss of mine this
leader is just Bonkers and it's just the
way it is and I just put up with it when
we move on
so what do you think about that well we
have to hurry because I have a meeting
with your leader after this oh sweet
what do you think about that uh gosh
that's a hard one and
but I kind of agree I think that you've
you have to decide if you can stay
um but unless they're doing something
unethical
I just don't see a way that that works
out well if you go to their leader
um that's a hard that I don't see a way
that that ends well
if it's like that person's annoying or
that person's just rude or I don't agree
I don't like the way they're doing shut
up you know what I mean like I I decide
to be there don't be there all right we
have to learn how to work in those kind
of because you're not everybody that you
work for is not going to be your
favorite person ever right and if that
person keeps making racist jokes that
person's that person's fudging the
numbers yeah we're gonna have another
conversation absolutely yeah all right
um I run a meeting and two people in the
meeting don't get along it's awkward for
everyone else how do I handle it you
call those two people in a room and say
hey we're grown-ups we're not children
we're gonna solve this problem right now
in fact I'm you don't need me to leave I
need to know what's going on here
because this is affecting everybody else
and if you all too can't get this
together y'all are opting out of working
here you gotta go because I'm not gonna
have YouTube people disrupt this whole
thing
and that as a leader that's my job is to
call them in and and deal deal with that
situation that's great all right last
one what is the worst career advice
you've ever received Follow Your Passion
so stupid follow your passion
if that was the case I'd be raising
unicorns like in Ireland something like
so stupid fault actually that's not my
passion at all I think
um I think that's just poor awful stupid
misguided
follow what makes you feel good that's
so stupid
um
most people most of the time become
passionate about what they're really
really good at and you only get really
good at something when you do it over
and over and over and you practice it
and you get lots of reps in and you fail
and you get back up and you go and most
of us only practice something that hard
when somebody's pushing us whether it's
a boss or a coach or a parent
and so ultimately you go all the way
down that line most of us are really
passionate about the things that we do
and the things that we're good at
because somebody made us put us in
uncomfortable situations along the way a
few people I've met them will Rudder is
one of those guys he just sits in his
room and jams that guy doesn't need
somebody yelling at him you need to
practice he just practices and he's one
of the best guitarists I've ever heard
ever in my life ever
um most people I know don't have that
they had parents that made him take
piano and take piano and take violin and
whatever and then they became oh I'm
good at this and then when I play it he
or she smiles at me I'm gonna keep doing
this or this teacher high fives me and
I'm gonna get better I'm gonna get
better and then all of a sudden they're
rocking battle the Bands not quite like
done button but they're still rocking
that's all that's it that's it that was
it oh my gosh we are solving problems
here on this show we are definitely
changing the world Listen be a good
leader and if you don't know what you're
doing go to entree what's that
rainsolutions.com entree leadership
check them out
we'll get you they'll get you you get
your mind right when it comes to
leadership